today on the matt walsh show the daily
wire achieves a resounding victory at
the supreme court as biden's illegal and
insane vaccine mandate is blocked and
effectively killed also in more good
news college enrollment rates continue
to decline across the country we'll talk
about that and the top prosecutor in
baltimore is facing a slew of felony
charges related to fraud and perjury
meanwhile a convicted arsonist uh that
she set free from prison is speaking out
to the media he's opposed to his own
release yet he was released anyway plus
a study finds uh claims to find anyway
that people are more attractive when
they cover their faces with masks in our
daily cancellation the left is upset
about my
anti-universal voting rights stance for
a change of pace get this they've called
me racist i'll deal with that today and
much more on the matt wells show
[Music]
you know if you've been listening to the
show for a while you've probably heard
me talk about my helix mattress uh so
exciting news then helix has gone beyond
the bedroom and started making sofas
they launched a new company called all
form and they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
directly to your door so what makes an
all form sofa really cool for starters
it's the easiest way that you can
customize the sofa using premium
materials and at a fraction of the cost
of traditional stores you can pick your
fabric the sofa color the color of the
legs sofa size and much more and also
the shape to make sure that's perfect
for you and your home they've got arm
chairs and love seats all the way up to
an eight-seat sectional so there's
something for everyone you could always
start small and then buy more seats
later on if you want your all-form sofa
to grow
and change with you uh when you move and
if getting a sofa without trying it in
stores sounds a little bit risky you
don't need to worry you get 100 days to
decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months if you don't love
it they'll pick it up for free and give
you a full refund
and they also have a forever warranty
literally forever that all form is
offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners at allforum.com
allforum.comwalsh to find your perfect
soda sofa check out allforum.com walsh
you know i tend to subscribe to the to
the idea that you should expect the
worst and hope for the best but then
also know that your hopes are foolish
and futile and then resign yourself to
despair and failure this may not be the
healthiest psychological approach to
life you know it's not gonna make you
the most joyful person but it inoculates
you from
disappointment at any rate
and um that is why i didn't expect good
news honestly to come from the supreme
court's hearing on uh biden's vaccine
mandate i wasn't expecting good news it
was worth fighting we had to fight but
uh i i have little faith in the court's
ability to get anything right so i was
prepared for the worst
and for once for once my pessimism was
not vindicated as you've heard by now
the court announced on thursday that it
was blocking
biden's vaccine mandate for private
employers effectively killing it for
good even if the the sixth circuit rules
in favor of the mandate at some point in
the coming months which maybe they will
the supreme court has already made its
opinion known on the subject which means
that this mandate simply has no path
forward it will never see the light of
day it might linger on in the court
system for a while but it won't make its
way
out into the workforce where you have to
worry about it
why did the court block the mandate
well you can read the opinions which are
which are actually worth reading
but it all amounts to what we already
knew
the federal government has no
constitutional authority to impose this
kind of rule onto the american workforce
biden cannot unilaterally declare that a
certain medical decision
must be a prerequisite for employment
for every person in the country he
doesn't have that authority the mandate
was illegal it was also deeply immoral
as it sought to violate the autonomy
of the individual in a really profound
way you know we hear a lot about bodily
autonomy as it relates to issues that
have nothing to do with bodily autonomy
like abortion
but here is one where the phrase is
actually useful the president trying to
force a needle into your arm
for any reason at all
must be an infringement on your autonomy
if you have any autonomy at all if that
word means anything then it must apply
here
and on top of being illegal and immoral
it's also illogical
this point was not
featured as prominently in the supreme
court arguments but it's important even
decisive i think since the shot does not
prevent the spread of the virus anyway
and any any even potential argument
justifying the mandate melts away into
oblivion if the mandate could be
justified at all
which which it couldn't
but if it could that justification would
have to rest on the vaccine's ability to
stop the spread
that's the only way you could say that
there's any real public health interest
going on here
but it has no such ability not a
significant enough degree anyway and uh
and so the one potential defense of the
mandate is rendered moot so it has no
legs to stand on
and now it can't stand at all because
it's been shot down
now i do believe it's necessary to spike
the football
when you achieve a victory
for one thing because it's just so damn
satisfying to do
but two because it's important to
acknowledge uh the wins when they come
and this is a big one the daily wire was
first in line to challenge the mandate
in court soon followed by many other
employers and organizations
not enough i mean there were
most employers were willing to just go
along with it
and not fight at all
but you know we've been chanting do not
comply for months
and it's more than a slogan for a
t-shirt it's a battle cry now a victory
cry and a banner that we're going to
continue to march under into the future
because too many people have grown far
too accustomed
to simply doing as they're told
going along to get along cooperate
submit
so they don't make any waves so they
don't draw unwanted attention to
themselves
but if we're going to pull our society
back from the brink
and rescue ourselves from civilizational
ruin
we need to just rediscover the power of
the word no
that's what the daily wires mandate
challenge was all about we said no and
the no prevailed in this case
now it doesn't end here
because the tyrants will never stop
exploiting kovid in an effort to gain
more power for themselves
and beyond kovad we know that there are
many more battles to fight
if we will not comply has been our
battle cry at the daily wire for years
you know for years before that the
battle cry or rather the cry of
surrender among the losers and
submissives and bootlickers of our
culture has been
this isn't the hill to die on
you know they're constantly accusing
those of us who are in the fight the the
men in the arena as ten-year-old teddy
roosevelt said of dying on a hill do you
really want to die on this hill they
sputter helplessly
and as each successive hill is reached
they always find reasons why it's not
important enough to fight over
surrendering one hill after another
until there are none left to defend
so to answer that question yeah we will
die on this hill
and the next one
and the one after that if that's what it
takes
because we've given up far too much
ground culturally
and and we aren't willing to be a part
of the retreat
so we're standing our ground and the
great thing we've discovered about being
willing to die on the hill
is that sometimes you win you don't die
and you get to pop champagne and
celebrate your victory
other times you lose
but you go down swinging
and you cause as much damage to your
opponent as you can on your way down
setting the stage for the next fight
that's my attitude that's why i'm here
at the daily wire because it's an
attitude shared by the whole company we
won this fight
can't promise that we'll always win
you know they're going to be losses too
we can promise that we'll always fight
and that means something
i mean these days i think it means
everything really
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
we're all getting killed at the gas pump
right now you got to find any way that
you can to save some money especially
when it's a really easy way um like this
the get upside app my listeners are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas at uh with get upside every time
they fill up just download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code walsh and
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back don't pay full price of the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
all you have to do it's very easy
download the app for free and use promo
code walsh to get up to 50 cents a
gallon cash back on your first tank
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as 2 2 300 a month in cash back
and there's no catch the cash back gets
added to your account you can cash out
any time to your bank account paypal you
can use a you get a gift card for amazon
and other brands as well just download
the free get upside app and use promo
code walsh to get up to 50 cents a
gallon cash back on your first tag again
that's get upside codewalsh it's free
with the get upside app
you know of all the cliches um the
cliche that uh opposites attract is
probably the truest in my experience and
couldn't be more true of me and my wife
certainly so just an example yesterday i
was at uh i went to fox news uh i did a
fox news hit uh fox prime time and i
told my wife to meet me at the studio
not not here but the studio where we do
the
the fox news hits in town uh because
we're gonna go out to dinner afterwards
and um so she comes to the studio
and she's in the little like waiting
room area and i go in to do the hit
and i'm on camera for maybe like five
minutes or less four minutes maybe
and i come out
and my wife has has made friends with
the makeup artist and she's sitting in
the makeup chair
at the studio getting her hair and
makeup done
for no reason just like for fun she's
not going on air
and then we leave and she's telling me
all about the makeup artist who i see
all the time there
but she's learned more about this woman
in five minutes than i have in five
months
and she somehow established this deep
connection and friendship in the span of
time that it took me to film a fox news
segment
i mean i could be around someone for 10
years
and not learn anything about them like i
might not even know their names
and she'll make a new best friend in 95
seconds
it really is amazing i swear sometimes
like she'll be she'll be texting someone
and i'll say oh who's that and she'll
say oh it's it's uh sarah
you remember sarah i was like no sarah
who are you talking about she said oh
you know she's the woman that i met um
at the gas pump last tuesday
and she was pumping gas across from me
and now we're best friends
i don't get it i don't understand how
it's possible
but uh
as i said i i could not be further on
the other end of that spectrum
all right let's uh
i've got a couple clips here to play for
you first the white house reacting to
their defeat
uh jen pasaki saying you know it's uh
well she was given a chance to respond
and i guess we'll listen i mean does she
offer any kind of explanation as to why
the decision was wrong does she have any
kind of constitutional explanation
uh let's find out
the supreme court's decision on the osha
mandate essentially means that in the
pandemic it is up to individual
employers to determine whether their
workplaces will be safe for employees
and whether their businesses will be
safe for consumers so president biden
you'll see this in his statement will be
calling on and will continue to call on
businesses to immediately join these
those who have already stepped up
including one-third of fortune 100
companies to institute vaccination
requirements to protect their workers
customers and communities we have to
keep working together in order uh to uh
get this done to save more lives
i would note that there are a couple of
um signs good signs in terms of uh
without this um
even even in spite of the ruling that we
would point to one is that 57
according to a navigator poll of
americans support vaccine requirements
okay so there's she's got nothing uh
there's no constitutional argument here
she has no explanation as to why the
decision was actually wrong
instead she says well we're relying on
employers to just do it anyway
and the thing is lots of them
will but we have to remember that they
have no justification to do it no reason
to do it they don't have to do it
if your employer still requires vaccines
for you it's not something they have to
do they're choosing to do it
and that's one of the reasons we talk
about the fight continuing the fight
continues
um
employers that still require the vaccine
as a condition of employment which again
many plenty
still will you may not have the same
kind of constitutional issue because
this is not an official government
mandate anymore because that's been shot
down
but it's still i believe a human rights
issue
and so that those are are people who are
subject subjected to these mandates even
on the employer level who need to be
defended
um i don't think that at this point
we simply declare victory on the vaccine
mandate and then move on to the next
thing
because there are lots of uh people who
are still gonna be subjected to them and
it's still wrong
um biden
here he is yesterday calling for this is
before the the
the decision on the mandate came down
and here he is calling for censorship of
his political opponents you know we're
told that um
social media censorship is not a first
amendment issue at all
not a free speech issue
because these are private organizations
that are making these decisions to
censor political speech
but what happens when the when they're
doing it at the behest of the president
let's listen
unfortunately while our military's
stepping up as they always do
there are others sitting on the
sidelines
and we're standing in the way
if you haven't gotten vaccinated do it
personal choice
impacts us all
our hospitals our countries
i make a special appeal to social media
companies and media outlets please deal
with the misinformation and
disinformation that's on your shows
it has to stop
covet 19 is one of the most formidable
enemies america has ever faced
we've got to work together not against
each other
yeah work together we all come together
to do exactly as i say
so um are we willing to
consider the possibility that there
might be constitutional issues now first
amendment free speech issues
when the president is instructing
social media companies to censor speech
oh but it doesn't count because it's
only it's only misinformation
it's only misinformation that we're
censoring
who decides what's misinformation well
uh
the powers that be
the administration the regime they
decide know that's that's one of the
problems with even calling
these big tech companies private
companies
maybe in in name only
but their relationship to political
power certainly blurs those lines
and the way that they act as tools of
political power
or rather
one side of the
that uh power structure anyway the way
they act as as tools as vessels
of political power certainly continues
again to blur those lines
now i think you have a real you know if
you end up getting banned from social
media
allegedly because of misinformation
misinformation that uh that has been
declared misinformation now but maybe a
week from now because fauci says it or
the cdc says it now it's not
misinformation anymore doesn't mean
you're getting your platform back
you're still gone
but if it happens after biden calls for
it instructs that it must happen
i think there are real constitutional
issues there
continuing biden also
we hear again his claim that wearing a
mask is your it's what makes you a good
american if you want to prove you're a
good american prove that you love your
country do your patriotic duty well then
cover your face in public you disgusting
ugly freaks
that's biden's message let's listen
in public places you should wear the
mask
and you're
there there are a lot you know
lots of different kinds of masks out
there
and the center for the center for
disease control and prevention the cdc
says that wearing a well-fitting mask
of of any of them is certainly better
than not wearing a mask it was well
fitting what foot over your nose
and but it's about one-third about
one-third of america's report they don't
wear a mask at all
as i've said in the last two years
please wear a mask
if you're in a you know i i think it's
part of your patriotic duty it's not
that comfortable
it's a pain in the neck
but
i've taken every action i can as
president to require people to wear
masks in federal buildings and on
airplanes and trains because they're
internet they cross state lines
i make sure that our doctors and nurses
and first responders have the masks they
need
no matter how many times i hear that it
will never stop being extremely creepy
to hear the president say that your
patriotic duty is to cover your face in
public
that's how you prove you're a good
american that's how you do patriotic
duty is to cover your face
and as always because we know again how
the missing the claim the misinformation
goes
he's not engaging at all with the actual
data and the facts
i mean we've we've heard from
representatives of the airline industry
saying that the mask mandates that
masking on planes is not necessary
it's a it's a just a charade
because in terms of as far as viruses go
or really almost any physical thread the
safest place you could be
there's 35 000 feet in the air
um
in a in a giant metal tube it doesn't
always feel the same especially for me
as someone who experiences a lot of
anxiety flying but it is
and you're breathing heavily filtered
air
um that is uh you know and you've got
air piped in from outside the plane
which is as clean as it could possibly
be
but that's um that still counts as
misinformation i guess
until until we until until an approved
authority figure says it that's
misinformation
all right let's move to this from the
daily wire says colleges and this is
more so this is uh actually we're doing
some good news on the matt well show for
a change and uh we started with good
news here's some more good news colleges
are experiencing an intense drop in the
number of students enrolling in classes
to receive undergraduate degrees showing
a trend that might not taper off with
the end of the pandemic
god willing
new data released on thursday by the
national student clearinghouse showed
that u.s colleges universities
experienced the decline of almost 500
000 undergraduate students in the fall
of 2021
keeping up with a drop that started in
the fall prior the national student
clearinghouse data showed that quote
continued enrollment losses in the
pandemic represented total a total
two-year decline of five percent
or nearly a million nine hundred thirty
eight thousand nearly a million students
since the fall of 2019 it added that
undergraduate enrollment
fell by 3.1
or 465 000 students over the last year
while graduate enrollment is down less
than half a percent
um
there was also a difference in the
topics that students are signing up to
study
it says the report noted enrollment in
each of the five largest undergraduate
majors at four-year colleges fell
steeply this year liberal arts declined
the most
while computer sciences and psychology
also
grew rather by 1.3 and 2.5 respectively
so we can
uh we can pin a lot of this probably on
the on on covid
but whether or not the the trend is
going to reverse as we get out of covet
if we're ever allowed to be out of covid
in any kind of official capacity that's
that's an open question
and i'm hoping that what happens
is that just like with um with the
public school system
you know
we've seen
homeschool rates incline precipitously
and
you might say that again if we ever are
allowed to be free of covid or free of
the the all the anti-covet measures
anyway
that maybe those trends will go back
down and it might decline a little bit
but i think what's happened with the
public school system and homeschooling
is that lots of families were forced to
do it and uh
they would not have done it otherwise
but they were forced to
and because they were forced to do it
they discovered many of them that hey i
can do this
this is better for my kids
to be homeschooled not not to sit on
at home on a computer doing remote
schooling that's like the worst of all
worlds where they're still in public
school but they're doing it through a
computer
but no actual homeschooling
parents discovered
i can do it
it's good for my kids and even i enjoy
doing it what do you know i actually
like
being around my own kids
for the majority of the day
you know i like being a full-time parent
not a part-time parent
where
more than half of the parenting duties
is siphoned off to the to the school
system
so that's been a that's been a
revelatory moment for a lot of parents
and i hope
that something similar is happening with
the university system
where families that otherwise without
covid probably would have shipped their
kids off to a four-year institution
they're not doing it for whatever reason
now and uh maybe you're gonna have
people discovering that hey you know
what
this this is fine
i was gonna go to college i didn't end
up going
i got a job
i don't have all this debt and i'm doing
well
now the scare tactics that kids are
taught in the school system and i know
because i went through this myself even
though i didn't go into a four-year
institution
but i remember i remember the scare
tactics very well
and they make it really clear to you
that if you don't go to college
you know
your life's gonna be a failure
you're going to end up on the street
you're going to end up it's having a
miserable
life
whereas if you go to college then
success and happiness await you
a a utopia a utopian future awaits if
you just go to college i can remember
those uh those those tactics very well
and that's what all these kids are going
through it's only gotten more it's only
gotten worse as time goes on
um
but maybe some of these kids have
realized that that's not exactly true
this will be this would be one of the
best things for this country i'm telling
you one of the best things for our
country the best things for our culture
would be this this trend here five
percent decline in enrollment
if that keeps going down
you know what i would love to see
my my uh
utopian future or as close to utopia as
you're gonna get which is still pretty
far away is like how about a 90 decline
in college enrollment
that's what it should be
you take all the kids that are enrolled
in college right now
maybe 10 of them maybe
should actually be there because
they want to be
doctors lawyers engineers architects
they want to be literal rocket
scientists or whatever
clearly you need
more
formal schooling to go into those lines
of work
but the vast majority
of jobs that you're going to take on
do not actually require a four-year
institution
in order to do them
because the vast majority of jobs
almost everything you learn
you're going to learn on the job
and uh and most of it's gonna be like in
your first week
so you could go to school for four years
and then go get a job somewhere
and you're gonna learn more in the first
week
relevant to that job than you learned in
four years by far
the problem is that although
the vast majority of jobs don't actually
require a four-year institution don't
actually require a college education
there's an artificial requirement that
these employers have put in place
for a lot of reasons one of them is just
pure laziness
that they're trying to streamline the
recruitment process as much as possible
and it makes it a lot easier if they can
just throw out half of the applicants
because they don't have a little piece
of paper
never mind the fact that many of those
applicants you're you might be throwing
out the best applicants
that's what it's really about for the
employers just whittling down the pool
um and and even if you're doing it in a
way that's unfair and doesn't make any
sense you're just whittling it down
making a lot easier
that's why i i've been saying for a long
time that
when we talk about the student debt
problem
um
in all of these things related to higher
education we need to be putting more
blame and pressure also on the employers
who are driving this there's the
universities who are driving it
obviously the banks the government the
school system i mean all these are
accomplished but but but the employers
also are
for putting these artificial
requirements in place when they know
that it's not necessary
this would be the best thing for the
country
you know what i wish i could say
we talk about college education
and we say well you know you need to be
able to use your college education and
when we say use it what we mean is
go and
get a job
and profit
off of it
that's what it's become so it's of
course sort of this real utilitarian way
of of using your education
but i wish it it weren't like that
i wish we could say that um that you
know you using your education the most
important way that you use your
education is simply by becoming a more
uh a more well-rounded intelligent
person
you're in an ideal scenario
it should be worthwhile to go and get an
education for its own sake
even if you never quote unquote use it
at a job
but it's not like that anymore it can't
be like that because the education is
way too expensive for that
you can't justify doing it for its own
sake because it's so expensive
and also the quality of the education
isn't good
it's something that you could probably
achieve on your own on the internet
and um
and oftentimes the education really just
amounts to left-wing brainwashing
so we're at a point now with the
education said with with the with
with colleges the university system
that it just it can't justify doing
going into it you can't justify sending
your kids into it unless they are going
to use it in the sense of
um professionally
all right
so let's take a look at this this is
from yahoo
baltimore state's attorney marilyn mosby
the city's top prosecutor
was indicted on thursday on federal
charges of perjury in filing false
mortgage applications related to a
purchase of two florida vacation homes
mosby a democrat elected to her post
2015 is accused of falsely claiming
twice to have suffered a work-related
financial hardship from kova 19 in order
to request early withdrawals totaling 90
000
from her city employer um
employer in both instances the
indictment stated mosby fraudulently
cited a cares act provision allowing for
emergency distributions of up to a
hundred thousand dollars from a
retirement plan in the event of a
furlough layoff quarantine reduced work
hours lack of child care or impact on
one's own business caused by cover 19.
and prosecutors said that mosby used the
money she received 36 000 in may 2020
and 45 000 on december 31st first of
that year toward down payments on
vacation homes
in florida
so this is the baltimore prosecutor
uh it's not even funny but what can you
do but laugh
defrauding the federal government and
using that money to buy homes in florida
now
one thing we know about mosby
before we knew that she was corrupt in
this way which is certainly no surprise
and the reason that's no surprise
is that mosby is one of these
prosecutors
among many in these major uh
cities that are all decrepit and falling
apart prosecutors that are very soft on
crime
and in her case why is she soft on crime
well because she's a criminal herself
she's got she's this is there's a lot of
self-interest that goes into this she's
a criminal herself she relates to
criminals because that's how she is
and uh that probably explains why she
isn't very enthusiastic about putting
criminals in prison
you know part of it is self-interest
part of it is that she really does
relate to these people
um and it's just kind of a general moral
debasement and derangement
that's why when we talked about this
last week i said we got to be very
careful
when we talk about these prosecutors who
are soft on crime
and the way that you hear some people on
the right criticize them they're still
criticizing them
by using the stereotype of the bleeding
heart liberal who's
overly sensitive and in fact if anything
has an over abundance of compassion and
that's the problem that's not it at all
there is no compassion these are morally
debased and deranged people
who when they
look at crime
they don't feel the
the visceral outrage that they should
feel on behalf of the victims of crime
they just don't care
it's a perfect example from mosby
the fox affiliate in baltimore had a
pretty incredible story a few days ago
that's before the the the news about her
be you know
getting arrested herself
a few days ago this story about a
convicted arsonist who attempted to burn
down his girlfriend's house with her
inside it admits that he wanted to kill
her
and yet was released from jail after a
few months when his 18 counts
was reduced down to one fox spoke to the
arsonist himself and even he says that
he should still be in prison listen i
was just charged with 18 different
counts
that was dropped to 10 and then it was
dropped to one
when i shouldn't be out right now do you
think that you deserve to be out of jail
[Music]
personally yes
but on a principal note no i disrupted
somebody's life
i traumatized somebody girlfriend i was
expecting to get time trent not the only
one surprised by the deal he was given i
didn't really know what to feel alexis
says the attorney in her case from
mosby's office alerted her to the news
the night before it doesn't seem that
justice the goals of justice have been
served here
it just seems like it's part of some
political game court records show trent
came back to the scene when police
arrived i wanted to see
what i did what i had done do you
consider yourself dangerous now that
you're out walking free after
facing three attempted homicide charges
no not really
um the reason why i say that is because
i had a serious lapse in judgment i
don't consider myself a dangerous person
well that does not give me a lot of
confidence i have to say that was not a
confidence inspiring answer do you
consider yourself a dangerous person uh
not really
i just had a lapse in judgment
that uh resulted in me trying to burn my
girlfriend alive
this was attempted
murder
by
with fire
and um he admits to it
and didn't go to prison
this is how this is how deep the
derangement goes in these cities
this is how deep it goes
a man who attempted to burn a woman
alive
mosby says yeah
yeah we'll give him a we'll give him
another chance
and and why is that again
there's a lot that goes into it
part of it as we talked about last week
at the deepest level this is an attempt
to overturn the moral order
um to dismantle civilization really is
what it's about this is this is this is
anarchy lawlessness
very intentional
and there's a reason there's a reason
behind it
but also
what drives it is that again these
these people they don't
for for those of us who are normal and
have any kind of functioning moral
compass we hear about a story like this
a guy that tried to burn out his
girlfriend girlfriend's house when she's
still in it in the house tried to burn
her alive
and and we we feel a number of things
immediately we feel outrage
at this guy and we want him punished for
what he's done
and we feel deep sympathy for the the
woman who suffered through this
very traumatizing event
and we also know that she's in danger as
long as this guy's allowed to walk
around on the street
so we have outrage at the the criminal
and we want the crime punished
and that's not about hatred that's
that's a yearning for justice
it is hatred in the sense that we hate
what he did
and maybe you even hate him that's
more than understandable
and that all comes from your desire for
justice a very healthy thing very
morally healthy psychologically healthy
and then also our sympathy for the
victim
but something like marilyn mosby and
these leftist prosecutors they don't
feel any of that
they don't experience any of that they
have no sympathy for the victims at all
and it's not that they have sympathy for
the criminals necessarily they just
don't care
it's indifference
that's the that's the great cancer in
our society right now is is indifference
all right i want to play this for you
britney spears is um
freed from her conservatorship and
that's you know that happened about a
month ago after this long public
campaign to free her from a
conservatorship
lots of people joined and there were
there were rallies and there were you
know activists they wanted
it's not fair that she's under
conservatorship and this was something
that that somehow crossed both
ideological
lines and
people on the left and right they were
together in this thing so we got a free
britney spears
now
one thing that i know general principle
here is that um
you know
if you hear the left calling for
something then you know it's almost
certainly wrong
but then when the other side agrees
most of the time you know that it must
really be wrong
and that i think is the case here so
britney spears was free from her
conservatorship
and she spent the last month i guess
just posting naked uh videos on
instagram and kind of rambling
incoherently
clearly demonstrating that she's a very
mentally disturbed person
or her sister jamie lynn spears has been
talking about her own experiences she
wrote a book apparently
uh trying to capitalize on all of this
but she did an interview a couple days
ago where she recounted just one of the
disturbing episodes that she recalls
from when she was a kid with britney
spears and
uh here she describes one let's listen
to that you describe an incident where
britney takes a knife
it says she's scared and locks you and
herself into a room
why did you want to include that
in the book
because first off i think that
experiencing my own panic attacks and
how sometimes we can
um
feel in those moments
is important but also it's important to
remember that i was a kid in that moment
i was scared that was an experience i
had
that's just one story locked in a room
with this raving lunatic with a knife i
mean who knows she was apparently just
paranoid and psychotic and and
hallucinating
um and this was my point all along with
it with the british spears
conservatorship and i you know i said
this so people were upset at me because
like i said on on the right this this
became a cause as well a banner that
they were marching under they got a free
britney spears merchant service ship and
my point all along was
what what are you people basing this on
what are you talking about you say well
she knows you should not be on a
conservatorship how do you know that
well you don't know her
you have no idea what's going on behind
the scenes
like there there are
a lot of famous
uh pop stars and celebrities out there
and
most of them are not under conservative
ships it's not like this is some sort of
far-reaching conspiracy
where it is like it of course this is
framed in like a patriarchal way is it's
because she's a woman and well there's a
lot of female pop stars out there that
are not on conservatorships
this one is
and maybe it's wrong maybe it's unjust
but the most probably logical assumption
is that there's a reason why she's been
singled out then when you consider that
she lost custody of her kids
which is almost impossible for a woman
to achieve especially in california
that tells you that something is very
very wrong
and she was judged you know a danger to
her own children
and all these people
based on nothing
they saw a documentary on netflix or hbo
or whatever it was
and decided based on that that we got to
release her from the conservatorship
for all you people know
she is a
clear and present danger to herself and
others for all you know
and you saw a documentary
he saw a 90-minute propaganda film and
just decided
you didn't need to know anything about
her psychological profile you didn't
know anything about what's going on
behind the scenes
in her own life you have no idea but
let's free her
and now she's free and you know what
my prediction
and i hope i'm wrong about this but like
something she she's going to hurt
herself or she and she or or someone
else or both
okay i i will be surprised that britney
spears is still with us in five years
so congratulations on your victory there
there's one victory that we should not
be spiking the football over um
okay finally here are some uh
fascinating findings from the coalition
of ugly people
the daily wire or rather the the daily
mail reports
people wearing face masks are deemed to
be more attractive than when they have
nothing covering their faces according
to a new study
face masks have become a common sight
around britain in response to the global
cove pandemic and cardiff university
researchers claim that the masks make
both men and women more appealing on the
eye
and they talk about how they
conducted this study they said the study
which began in february 2021
asked 43 women to rate images of men
based on attractiveness
the pictures were shown with the two
different kinds of face masks with a
book partially covering the faces and
with nothing covering the faces at all
both a blue medical mask and a plain
cloth mask were used in the study
and participants said that those faces
were
wearing surgical masks were the most
attractive
okay so doesn't this
i didn't i only saw the headline before
i decided to put this in five headlines
this this is this is the first time i've
read about the actual study and so they
had a selection of men
and then i assume they did this the
other way too with women
so a selection of people and then they
had pictures of them without masks
and pictures of them with masks
and then they surveyed some other people
and said who are they more attractive
with the massacre without
doesn't that just tell you that the
people in the pictures were really ugly
isn't that all that tells us
because that's the one community i would
say that has benefited
from the face mask ordinances
i think it's been horrible for everybody
it's been horrible for kids
the one community that is that's made
out like bandits literally
are ugly people
especially if you are in that category
where you are ugly
but you have nice eyes
then these last two years these have
been your years
and i'll give you that at least
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
says matt if you're snoring you should
see your doctor and go to a sleep
specialist for a sleep study they'll be
objective on whether you snore if you
snore you could have sleep apnea
please don't ignore this because snoring
can be medically dangerous
yeah
i'll just die then i guess
i mean i don't want to but
it there's just no and you're not the
first person to say this to me my wife
has also said this they got to go for a
sleep study
let's see like a sleep study where i get
where i go into some laboratory behind a
glass window and sleep while i'm being
watched
is that how that works just just no
scenario where i will ever do that
so i'm just going to ride this thing out
that's it that's my choice
anne says every day i listen to your
podcast and every day i say out loud
lord help his poor wife
you might think you're banned for that
and but
perfectly justified in fact i think the
same thing myself every single day
garrett says matt i think you'd be very
proud of me a few nights ago i went to
the grocery store to grab some food
after exiting the store and putting the
groceries in my car
i saw that the nearest cart return was
pretty far however despite it being dark
and 20 and sub 20 temperatures i
mustered up the courage and stamina to
hop back in my car and drive away
wait
leaving my car in the middle of the
parking lot
you bastard
you're i don't do i have to even say it
do i have to say it i will you're banned
um adam says alex stein uh alex stein
did that song and it was a joke he's got
a channel the joke was they let him go
on for over five four minutes okay we
played the uh the rap
the guy at some kind of
town hall meeting rapping about the uh
about the vaccine and i have been
informed in the comments
that this was apparently like a
conservative and it was all a parody or
satire so it was a troll
and i myself i i got trolled also
the troll has become the trolled so well
done alex finally kyle says only uh only
thing in life that is consistent is
change
change is inevitable that being said we
won't be able to go back to a simpler
time like before covid matt i'd like
your opinion on how do we go forward
from here where do we make positive
changes
that can make positive impacts
um
where do we make positive changes that
can make positive impacts
kind of a kind of a broad phrasing there
look
okay let's just talk about long game
and and and we we started the show
talking about the victory and how we
have to fight
i get this question a lot is is uh you
know
where do we go from here
can can we achieve a kind of final
cultural victory
and the answer to that
is no
not in our lifetime so we have to start
thinking about it long term and uh this
is what i've been saying to people for
years we have to settle in
and realize that we're in this fight
and we're we're not going to see the
sort of final victory where we reclaim
the culture and some semblance of real
sanity in our society i don't think
we're going to see that
because it took generations to get to
this point
and logic would tell us that it will
take generations to get us out if we do
so you're not going to see the victory
um your children
might but probably won't you were
talking more about your grandchildren
and your grandchildren's children
and that might seem depressing but but
in another sense it's i think it's kind
of encouraging
you've got nothing to lose this is what
your life is settle down
for the fight that's it
yesterday as you heard the daily wire
was part of history the supreme court
has blocked the buy administration's
outrageous vaccine mandate for private
employers uh and we know that this that
this uh that this decision was was very
important for freedom for employers and
uh it's going to protect all of us going
forward the daily wire is one of the
first in the nation to file suit against
the obscene federal overreach and i'm
thrilled that the risk we took has paid
off the mandate itself set a dangerous
precedent that the unelected osha held
power over the personal medical
decisions of american citizens
because once it was decreed law it
wouldn't have stopped at big employers
this would have expanded to smaller
companies and on from there the supreme
court recognized this gross power grab
and has made the right decision we're so
proud to have led the charge in this
fight but we could not have done it
without you thousands of you joined us
and over a million signed our petition
against the mandate and we still need
you we're going to continue to take the
fight to the left because when it comes
to preserving our freedom you can never
rest so join us today at dailywire.com
subscribe and be a part of the
conservative movement to keep our
freedom and our values alive
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so once again
i must defend myself from the slings and
arrows of my fellow youtubers you would
think that there might be some kind of
like camaraderie between all of us
we might form a common bond
united as one community that's what i
want i constantly extend my hand in
friendship to my youtube neighbors but
my my friendly gestures are rebuffed
it's a tragedy
so today i'm i'm forced to enter the
ring once again
though in this case i'm afraid it may be
too late dr rashad ritchie is affiliated
with the young turks and he has his own
show on youtube called indisputable with
dr rashad ritchie
i'm not sure what his doctorate is i
assume he's not a medical doctor
as far as i can tell he has a phd in
race-baiting from al sharpton university
i say that my response may be too late
because his video attacking me is titled
dr ritchie destroys matt walsh for
bigoted opinions
i've apparently been destroyed
i don't feel destroyed
i didn't know that i was destroyed i
woke up this morning still
physically intact
but sometimes destruction can be a bit
more subtle i was a dead man walking i
didn't even know it
it's probably hopeless to even respond
to dr richie as i am now but a pile of
rubble yet i'll try to pull myself
together richie is angry with me
because of a segment on this show a few
days ago where i said that i'm not in
favor of universal voting rights
i don't support a system that allows
clueless non-contributing imbeciles to
vote and i think we should put some kind
of measure in place to filter out the
ignoramuses and societal leeches
richie didn't like that and so he set
out to destroy me let's see if he
succeeded
yep and i'm going to state this without
apology i think you're racist as hell
okay
let me explain to you why uh mr matt
walsh
uh you actually are being truthful about
what you believe i wish more republicans
would just say the way you're saying it
because at least we can deal with them
as they are without the trickery
involved
but you are entitled to your opinion and
i'm entitled to mine
and here's mine you actually are
connected to
the sentiment of the founding fathers of
this country because they did not want
everybody voting no
they wanted a particular class
of people to be able to vote
they wanted white men who owned property
i don't know about your financial
situation maybe you would have been
included in that or not but they only
wanted white men that own property
that's bigoted that's racist that's
sexist you got all of that in one
and you are connected to that sentiment
taxation my dear brother
taxation
without representation is what you are
advocating
i have to pay taxes every voter has to
pay taxes so you're telling me that we
should pay taxes until the american
governmental system the structure of
taxation which is constitutionally
mandated but we should not all have the
right to vote only select individuals as
you said the most competent and
qualified and i'm sure you want to pick
what competency and qualification is
you're rooted in bigotry racism and
classism
you rather
pick the voters
because you're scared
of the voters picking the politicians
it frightens you
but we come in
well
no false advertising there he did
destroy me
he called me racist
that's the end of the discussion i i am
i am vanquished i cannot recover
all he has to do is point at me and say
the r word and i melt away like the
wicked witch in the wizard of oz
at least that's how he thinks that this
will go and should go but unfortunately
for him i have a magic shield that
protects me from the racism charge
and on the shield has written the words
i don't give a damn
so you aren't going to shut me down by
calling me a racist because i don't care
about that label
i don't care if you think that about me
i'm not interested in trying to convince
you otherwise i don't care one way or
another
that word means nothing to me because
people like yourself have completely
emptied it of all meaning
you're gonna have to present actual
arguments not labels but you have very
few of those arguments to offer it would
seem so let's go through your points
such as they are
your first point and also your second
third and fourth points are that i'm
racist as we've covered
now we've established i don't care about
that but there's one other observations
we made related to that charge
in my case in my case against voting
rights
i never once mentioned race
i simply say that that terminally
ignorant people should not be able to
vote
at other points when talking about the
subject i've also expressed frustration
with the fact that non-contributors
societal parasites are able to vote
i've never racialized that sentiment
my position is quite simple i couldn't
possibly care less whether you're black
white or any other color if you're one
step above comatose and have no idea
what's happening in our country
and are barely even aware of what
country you live in
you should not be able to vote and there
should be a process in place to weed you
out
i have no opinion about how many members
of each race will be excluded through
this process i don't care
if one race
you know
every member of that race passes through
fine with me
if they're all excluded okay
it's not about the race for me
now i imagine a pretty large portion of
all races would end up on the democratic
cutting room floor if we put something
like that something like this in place
so be it doesn't matter to me
you rashad ritchie are the one who has
apparently decided that a basic voter
compensated competence of disaster would
exclude a disproportionate number of
black people i didn't say that you're
saying that
i said that ignorant dummies shouldn't
vote
then you accused me of attacking black
people
you've connected dots that i did not
connect and do not connect
that's your issue stop projecting it on
to me
you also claim that my plan would amount
to taxation without representation
because we're all taxpayers and thus we
should all be able to vote except that
in fact we are not all taxpayers
we're certainly not all taxpayers to the
same degree in fact half of the
households in the u.s pay no federal
income tax at all
and i believe that number's actually
gone up significantly over the last year
or so now if you're suggesting that only
taxpayers should be given the right to
vote then you and i could actually reach
a compromise
i'd like to see more qualifications put
in place than that but disenfranchising
non-taxpayers would certainly be a good
start
after all the flip side of the taxation
with our without representation
coin
is representation without taxation
which is also
unjust if it's not if it's not equally
applied
right if there's some people that are
taxed some people who aren't
both get to equally represent themselves
in the voting booth
that's not fair because it allows people
to have a say in a system that they have
no financial stake in and are not
contributing to
and what happens is that they can vote
themselves money from the public
treasury
even as they're not putting anything
into the pot themselves
so it's a fundamentally unjust and out
of balance system
yet
now you could you could uh alleviate
some of my concerns in that area by like
getting rid of the welfare system for
example and entitlements and we could
have that conversation so that takes us
down a whole other road
but i'm guessing that you wouldn't be
satisfied with that compromise or with
the taxpayer compromise
you cite taxation as an objection to my
voting proposal but in fact
you don't think taxation should actually
have any bearing on voting rights at all
you simply use that as a cudgel when
it's convenient to do so
you give me credit for saying what i
really mean i wish i could give you
credit for the same but you're guilty of
the same kind of trickery quote unquote
that you accuse your opponents of
engaging in
now you say that i'm scared of the
voters picking the politician
you're right
i am i mean you you have not uncovered
any deep or secret truth i'm very open
about it
it terrifies me that people who think
that the term
branches of government refers to actual
trees are nonetheless able to decide
who's in charge
it terrifies me because because of this
corrupt and evil politicians are able to
exploit this ignorance and this
stupidity
and we are living through the results
today
we talked about baltimore
many american cities now
lay effectively in ruins
because clueless incompetent easily
manipulated voters select people who
promise to destroy their own
neighborhoods torch their communities
and make their quality of life
demonstrably worse
and these voters select them anyway
the competent voters who know better are
then forced to live in the ruins
that this self-destructive stupidity
brings about
it doesn't have to be that way
it's a problem that can be solved
but we can't solve it because people
like yourself would rather the dummies
vote because you know that your policies
won't be enacted any other way
and that's why today dr ritchie i have
to say unfortunately
that you are cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day and a great weekend
talk to you monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo
ledowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin